[Lon Phan] Okay, Peter, thank you for the
introductions.
And as was mentioned my name is Lon Phan,
project lead for dbSNP and also for this project.
So today we will be going over introduction
of ALFA project, for those new to the project
and also we will go over a little bit of the
data in the first release, the data we released,
and then right into the tutorials, learn how
to access the data and then we will conclude
with some questions and Q&A.
I would encourage you to visit the project
home page, there is a lot of details about
the project and also in addition if you attended
previous webinars, including this, the ALFA
project introductions and a lot of the material
I will not cover today will be on this webinar
and the various services, like today's talk
in the presentation.
So this project is to provide aggregate allele
frequencies from dbGaP, and our goal is to
provide data from over 1 million subjects.
I will use this as an introduction to dbGaP,
this dbGaP page.
So dbGaP is a database of genotypes and phenotypes.
It stores studies, thousands of studies, and
the result of looking at the association between
genotype and phenotype and effect on of course
the genes and everything else.
It also has thousands of phenotype data sets
and hundreds of thousands of variables and
millions of subjects.
And it also contains a lot of molecular data
set including all the genotyping so this shows
you that there are millions of subjects that
have been genotyped on various platforms including
micro arrays and direct sequencing from exome
and whole genome.
So this project is to provide, aggregate all
this heterogeneous data from diverse platforms
and then homogenize and normalize and put
it in a standard format.
And then data will be integrated to dbSNP
release and then be available through various
methods.
If you already use dbSNP this should be very
little change to your current pipelines.
So this is a brief summary of the data flow
so again we select approved study in the dbGaP
and then the QC process and then we compute
and analyze the subject and their ancestry
and assign them to a population.
All the data from the various platforms are
converted into a standard VCF format.
Then go through a computational pipeline,
normalize the variants, aggregate and compute
the frequency and then provide the products.
I will not go into the detail how the variants
are normalized but just to say that this has
led to improvement in terms of the RS assignment
and clustering and reduce a lot of the issues
in the previous builds where we had duplicate
RefSNP and things like that.This normalization
has been published and there is also a webinar
from about a year ago, linked on the project
home page.
So we had our first release about a month
ago.
And just starting with a modest 42 studies
and that included about 100,000 subjects,
half a trillion genotypes and the output is
that this clusters down to about half 1 billion
unique variants and most of those already
existed in dbSNP but we also found some novel
variants.
This is just comparing with various projects
that had been released before.
ALFA is comparable in terms of scale and scope
with other projects such as the gnomAD and
TOPMED and ExAC in terms of the number of
subjects and variants, okay?
This is showing the breakdown in terms of
populations from the initial release.
It is still biased or primarily European but
we do have some numbers for the continental
larger populations.
But our future plan is to improve and increase
the number of these subjects of the underrepresented
populations.
But again initially we had what hundred thousand
subjects.
But this is just a small fraction of the available
subjects in dbGaP so there is almost 2 and
a half million subjects that have genotypes
and almost 1,000,000 1/2 subjects which are
possible candidates for the ALFA project so
look for more data coming.
We also looked at comparing the data from
our project with the other projects and we
see the stack in terms of concordance, quality,
and in terms of the ancestry and the variants
in the population.
So here what we are looking at is compare
the ALFA data, the minor allele frequency,
versus thousand genome project.
so the 1000 genome minor allele frequency
is plotted on the X axis and alpha is on the
y-axis and for each of the common populations.
So they both agree in terms of what the same
variant and just a 45-degree line on the angle.
And as you see, our ancestry, for the populations
and the variants, pretty consistent with 1000
genome and we set these blue lines indicating
the outliers so we see it is pretty stringent
and that difference of plus or -0.15.
And even then we have very few variants.
These are AIMs informed markers that were
used to do the the different comparisons and
their very few outliers.
And we also did the same thing with nomad
and topmed to show that there is good concordance
between our data and these other projects
in terms of quantity and concordance.
And also the ancestry too if you compare the
1000 genome and alpha the European population
is very similar and we are a pretty good in
assigning population groups.
And we also look at other variants of interest
such as the variants of ClinVar and GTR and
these mainly contain the drug response markers
and also variants in dbGaP, the GWAS Catalog
with associations, p-values, of less than
10 to the minus five to some particular trait
or phenotype.
Then we also looked at variants in terms of
those that had been cited in publications
and description of phenotypes or biological
effects of the variants.
As you see here even with the small amount
of subjects we started with we have pretty
good coverage for most of the other resources.
And if you want to get a subset of these data,
it's in VCF format you can get from the FTP
site in the supplemental material.
heeps://ftp.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/snp/population_frequency/latest_release/supplement/
So the ALFA frequency data reported on the
RefSNP page, it is in the frequency tab and
as you see here we have the total population
and total project across the studies, the
frequency and then we have the simple size
and the reference allele and we have the frequency
and then the continental subpopulation.
For this particular one.
European, African, Asian and so on.
We also provide you population frequency when
it is available for a variant from over hundreds
of other projects that dbSNP in the found
1000 genomes, exac, nomad and you can compare
the data across projects.
So now we will start diving into the tutorial
or the walk-through in terms of how do you
actually find the variants.
How do you get to the RS page find the variant?
So you can start that with searching dbSNP
and we provide a document here
https://www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/snp/docs/entrez_help/
that provides our supported search terms,
but it includes the RS number, and you can
search both GRCh37 and 38 positions.
In Gene both the symbol and geneID.
And also other attributes like the frequency
range, ClinVar clinical significance and many
others.
So we will go here and take a look.
So this is the help page for all of the supported
search fields and terms of dbSNP and we provide
you field name, aliases and description and
some of the possible values you could use
for it.
Here you can search for GRCh38 position [position]
and GRCh37 position [position_grch37].
ClinVar clinical signigicance [clin]
and gene [gene] and so on.
There are also some examples down here too.
So I will pause here for second and I will
mention that we will be adding additional
attributes specifically for ALFA projects
and it will be easier for you to search for
a variant that has ALFA projects . Unfortunately
we did not get it done for this webinar but
that should be in the next field release in
the next week or so.
But because the system is so robust I think
we can get lucky and we can proceed with a
demonstration how to find a variant with ALFA
specific frequency.
So we will go back to here.
So here is a sample of search we will do today
and let me pull this to full-screen.
So we can look for a ClinVar variant that
has specific interpretation of pathogenicity
and perhaps the frequency can inform you or
provide some insight about what the effect
of the variant is.
We also want to find one where there it is
cited in publications so that maybe we can
find via text mining search and read about
the phenotype and biological effects.
And then we will go through some other attributes
like missense variant, and whether it is clustered
by validations.
What this means is that it has been submitted
to dbSNP multiple times, it has been observed
by multiple submitters, essentially it is
a validation with dbSNP but should be useful.
The variant may be real in that it was observed
independently multiple times.
But we also look for one that has no frequency
from any project so hopefully the only frequency
it has is from the ALFA, okay?
So this is pretty complex query and even if
you have to do this by sql or other means,
it is still pretty complex but I will show
you how easy it is and you can do it in dbSNP.
So the query we have to generate is this,
and don't be scared by this because I will
show you how to do this using two methods,
using the filter and the Advanced search within
the Entrez search system and we can generate
this query without you even touching the keyboard.
So we'll proceed with that now.
The query I just did returned four results,
four variants.
Okay.
So this is pretty complex query and has a
lot of things joining and stuff like that
so just shows you how robust this is.
So how do you generate this query without
touching the keyboard?
So if we just go to the start tab, so if you
start new, you can go to the dbSNP homepage
and go to the search box and of course as
a reminder there is a link to the ALFA project
here and below that we have some of the example
search terms and also additional link to the
help page but here you will see a filter here,
all[sb] that will show you all of the records
available through dbSNP so we will pull it
up and then use the filter to narrow down
the data.
So that is fairly quick return over half 1
billion records in no time.
Okay so here are the filters I'm talking about
on the left side and you look at that, so
we will go ahead and check off the pathogenicity,
ClinVar variants with conflicting interpertation
of pathogenicity, that drills down to a few
thousands and then you will go further, we
want it to be cited in publications.
They are RS's so we can have a lot of information
about it and we will click on missense and
it does not change the number that much, now
it is down to 248 and then we will want it
validated by cluster.
So that takes us down to the 248 but as you
see here these still have frequency data as
reported here, and we are showing you the
different projects that have low-frequency.
Like I mentioned earlier, in the next build
one of these lines that include the ALFA frequency.
But right now we do not have it.
Okay, so then back to the 248 One option you
can go to is - it also generates the query
over here - you can edit that but like I said
you can do this without touching the keyboard.
And then we can go to Advance.
So this is the Advanced Search Builder page,
and this will be the search box, terms, here
is the builder and then there are some searches
down here, recent searches, so initial search
we had four.
And then this is as we drill down the filter,
stores history too.
So we will go ahead and include this in the
query builder so it puts that in there.
But then we will go here and we will select
NOT and then exclude everything but frequency
data submitted by other projects.
So select Validation Status and then by frequency.
And that is it.
And now it will search but exclude any with
frequency data, so we will do a search.
And there it is.
Only four records.
Frequency is no longer reported for these,
right?
There is still detail here, the variant type
and all that, the position, allele, and of
course attributes will be selected, missense,
and conflicting pathogenicity and all of that,
by cluster and publication and so on.
We will talk about this one, the RS, first
result.
And see what the frequency can reveal or tell
us about the variant.
So if we go here this is the detailed, RS
report page and again the variant details
up here and summary information, and then
over here we have some various tabs for the
different data sections.
Clinical Significance, Frequency, it is here
the ALFA frequency data.
It shows the frequency across all studies,
sample size, Ref allele, Alt allele, and then
the subpopulations.
Of course there are no frequencies from other
populations like topmed or exac.
Okay, so this shows you that this variant
allele is pretty common across most common
populations where we update the data.
So if you go to the clinical significance,
what does that tell you?
All the data integrated here on the page,
you can see it is easy to get all the data
through the clinical assertions.
So here is one that has conflicting interpretation,
so click on that ClinVar accession.
Again so this takes me to the ClinVar page
and shows you about the variant details again
and the conditions, and then down here you
have clinical assertions to submitted by different
submitters, OMIM and GeneReviews.
Then the Evidence section, you can drill down
to detail and what was provided in terms of
how they asserted the clinical significance.
So here is OMIM and we will click on that
to look.
And I think you see here, this variant is
found in 40% of the patients.
But then down here it is found in 13% of the
general population which is consistent with
what ALFA reported, right?
It is the teens, and this is a general common
variant.
Anyway, that may provide some insight into
what does that mean and so on like that.
But also important, I want to go back to this
page, is that this provides you a beacon in
a sense into dbGaP and what this tells you
is they actually have 1000s of subjects that
carry this variant so you can go into dbGaP
and get the actual genomtype and investigate
it further, to look at the variants, or interrogate
the genotype of those individual in more detail.
Or get the phenotypes and the attributes that
have been described in dbGaP and how they
are associated with the variant, okay?
So that is really the power of this connection
between variant and the dbGaP data, right?
And here is the frequenccy that ALFA reported.
So that was that.
How we do for the web search.
And next we'll move into how do you do this
programatically.
And we start using the EUtils.
Again we have a help document here
https://www.ncbi.nlm.nih.gov/snp/docs/entrez_help/
specifically for the dbSNP and how to use
the eutils with dbSNP data.
But anyway, essentially you use the same syntax.
You can use the web to develop and test your
query, put it in the code with the same syntax
and We have these tutorials in a jupyter notebook
and we will go over that now.
dbSNP has a github site and we have a tutorial
section, directory, and within that there
is a bunch of tutorials you can walk through
and we will go ahead and look at this one
in Binder.
While it is loading, it will do it slowly
and I will explain what is going on here.
We load the standard Python modules, biopython
modules and import an Entrez library module
and then we will use that to query dbSNP using
E search, and then the use the same general
same terms used for the web and then, great,
almost done.
I will go ahead and run it all and get us
started.
It is loading up, slowly.
Here we are using usehistory="y" with that
and we essentially get a key back so we can
manipulate the data or retrieve it in batches
and retmax=20 to return twenty records.
So here, it looks like we ran it and here
we getting the query, essentially qeury.handle,
through the Esearch and we give it the query
and then we get the results and then here
are some parameters that returned with the
results, and it helps you decide what you
want to do with it.
For this query it only returns five RS and
then here is the ID list, parameter.
And then this is the QueryKey that we used
and there is some translation detail down
here, so if you get zero results back then
you might want to dig into the details to
see if it took your query correctly.
So we get the RS list, a print out of the
RS numbers.
And put it there and then go ahead and pass
those query parameters that we got back from
E search into efetch and then here it has
downloaded the XML for each of those records
and that is that.
So we could just do this, I'll copy this,
just to show it to you, the demonstration.
And then paste it in here.
All right, got it.
Go that and so the previous query returned
five, this one returned four.
The nice thing about jupyter notebooks is
you can interact and play with it and experiment
with it and then even edit the code and once
you are done you just go here and you download
the Python code and you are done and you are
ready to use, okay?
That was a simple example and not we will
walk through a little more complicated example.
All right.
In addition to the Eutils and Entrez we also
have another one called NCBI variation service
API so this is like a Swiss Army knife or
toolbox as you can imagine because it is also
like remapping, and it does conversion between
different notations like HGVS, VCF, RS number
and our own internal conversions and recently
began supporting [Indiscernible] via varitation
objects.
Like a said this has been covered in a webinar
a year ago and there's a link on the bottom
of the ALFA project webpage to the webinar
and I will not go into detail about that.
But just we did introduce three new concepts
specific for the ALFA project and that is
to retrieve the metadata about the project
or I mean the study, and, you know, the population
description.
And then there is one to retrieve all the
variants within the sequence interval.
And then also of course to get the frequency
by the RS ID numbers and we will walk through
some examples now.
So we have developed a bunch of tutorials
and put in the jupyter notebooks again and
included for how to search by gene and RS
numbers and using VCF as an input and so on.
So we will go over there.
Okay.
In addition we have other tutorials or notebook
on how to do the conversion between notation
that is described in the variation service
support.
And there also module, a wrapper around the
code and it's a little cleaner if you want
to use that as a wrapper around the API.
But here is how the ALFA specific notebook
and they are on Binder so you can just launch
them from here.
So we have examples for gene, RS and frequency
and a couple of other ones here and then one
for querying directly FTP.
We'll start with an rsid example because it
is simple.
It will take a second to load and again this
is while it is loading, it is loading standard
python modules and here is the call to get
the frequency for an RS number.
Basically you just submit an RS number and
that is it.
Then you will get the frequency, of that,
and I will go ahead and Run All.
Okay, also in addition to that, what this
does is -- here it is, it returns 16, a json
object for that RS number so it includes the
build ID number so if you maintain local database
and you want to be up-to-date you can compare
the build_id, it is essentially a string of
the date for the ALFA build.
And then the result contains the chromosome
number and the position, the reference allele,
and then the BioProject ID for this Alpha
Project and then allele counts for each of
the populations and the population is described
by the BioSample ID and then allele counts
for each of those populations.
Okay?
This also retrieved the meta data.
It is just a single parameter and it retrieves
the metadata and it essentially creates a
dictionary of the metadata.
If you want to show more common terms, you
can do that, translate it.
And then this is just some housekeeping stuff
but essentially this is the call for the RS
number and some error handling which you need
when doing web requests.
And then down here we put it all together
with the metadata and then print it out over
here, okay?
Like I said before, you can pretty much interactively
play with this and go ahead and put a new
RS number in here and run it and that you
get instant results and you can tweak and
fine-tune this or however you want for your
own purpose, okay?
We will get out of that notebook.
Next one, this one combines both -- so this
is a search by Gene ID.
Directly the Variant Services API does not
support the gene search, it only supports
search by position but you can get the gene
position from the gene database and then use
that to search the API.
So here we show you how to do that.
By integrating both the eUtils API and the
Variant services API -- let me just run these.
So this function up here gets the gene location
using the eUtils esummary and the current
Gene database to get the gene information
from the gene ID.
And then it just parses the location out and
then use that location to then search or query
the Varriant Services API to get the variants
within that region.
Okay, so again we just wrapped all this up
in terms of some error handling and some issues,
web requests exceptions.
So here we use that range, the query, actually
think it is called TP53, yes, so we have the
range from gene database and then queried
the database and so we get over 1300 variants.
And like I said before this shows you the
query actually used to you get the variants.
There is a limit for each query, 250 variants.
And so we can look at them and again this
returns a json object and you can parse that
out into a more friendly format.
And like I said most of this code up here
is to do iteraive handling of the request.
So this is kind of nice it shows you how to
integrate both the Eutils and the Variant
Services API.
And then this gives the flexibility so you
can really search for any genomic features,
like enhancers, promoters, and any other variants
using positions.
So another thing I want to mention is when
you query the API, not only just getting back
the existing RS variant, but you also getting
novel variants that have been discovered by
ALFA.
The web searches, and of course there won't
be an RS page for it, but if you want the
latest, greatest data, the API and the FTP
download is where you can get both the existing
and novel variants, okay?
I will just go over here.
So we went through RS numbers, retrieval by
RS, by gene.
So we are almost out of time so I will not
go into this but you might want to take a
look at this one, it does remapping it takes
as input GRCh37 VCF remaps the query to the
h38 with the API.
We will go quickly go into this one quick,
the Google Colab one, this queries the FTP
VCF.
The reason you want to use this is if you
have a firewall say and you want to use the
FTP download or for whatever reason, limitations
due to web requests and you can use this.
But this actually queries the ALFA FTP VCF
and as I mentioned before it contains both
existing variants and novel variants.
Quickly, it is just importing the standard
tabix Python module.
Here we have some handling for the large request,
housekeeping stuff.
And then it just queries the FTP site to get
the range, this is chromosome 1, at this position
and return the data and it is in VCF format,
a brief header and then the standard positions
and the rsid if it is available, if it's novel
it would not have an rsid and then Ref and
Alt allele and then the population BioSample
ID and then the allele counts, okay?
There is a bunch of other housekeeping functions
and then also you can have meta data if you
want to map, say the BioSample ID to standard,
common terms, and then the print out is down
here and like I said you can tweak around
or play around with the ranges or whatever.
And then it will iterate through and just
keep pulling the data.
So that pretty much concludes the webinar
today in terms of the tutorial.
So I want to conclude by saying that this
is a growing data set, we are probably at
less than one percent of what is available
in dbGaP.
So look for an avalanche of new data coming
in the future.
We will be updating this regularly and try
to get quarterly updates and try to discover
novel variants and update the frequency data.
Another key thing is that we have essentially
done lot of the heavy lifting and taking the
heterogeneous data and normalizing it both
in terms of variants, the subjects, population,
and the exchange format so we used to use,
and another KeyPoint again is that this provides
a beacon into dbGaP so that you can do authorized
access and apply to get the individual genotypes
and phenotypes and so on for further interrogation.
So with that, I will hand it back over to
Peter and follow up with questioning.
[Peter Cooper] Thanks, Lon and we have a lot
of questions and I don't think we will have
time to get through all of them.
One thing that came up a couple of times is
the aggregate data from dbGaP.
Those include studies that include cancer
patients, is that true?
[Lon Phan] Yes, so there could be some patience
in there but again the nice thing with dbGaP
is all the attributes have been captured,
so presumably in the future we could slice
and dice the data however so if you look at
the possibility in terms of number of attributes
and the measurement and you could slice and
dice it by cases versus control, age, sex,
different cohorts, whatever, how you want
so that possibilities are endless so that
is really the power but we are starting with
just general -- so yes.
We'll discover pathogenic variants as well.
[Peter] These would not be somatic variants,
would they?
The way these variants are generated?
[Lon Phan] Well it is hard because somatic
variants are typically hard to identify and
they may pass some filtering mechanism depending
on how the study was filtered.
We have done some analysis and we will share
that later but we do compare some of the variants
with other somatic databases to see if there
might be somatic variant candidates.
We did look at COSMID and I think a few other
cancer sites, so there could be some but again
frequency may inform you, right?
And if there is one or two person out of 100,000
or 1 million probably it is a rare mutation.
[Peter] Related to that and I think you alluded
to this a minute ago, will there be a way
later on to sort of get subset of these that
would not include for example, cancer patients?
[Lon] And right now we -- like I said this
is our initial reason and this resource, and
the directions that we can take will depend
on what feedback we get from you so we want
people to use this data as much as possible
and drill down to it and what is useful and
what is not and the more feedback we get from
the user the more that helps us to prioritize
in terms of what we where we will take it
and there are millions of ways you can slice
and dice this data.
So we encourage users to you use it, please
provide feedback, and what you would like
to see, what you don't like or any issues.
And it can help improve for everybody else
and that you can or we can really use feedback
and comments.
[Peter] So you can always send them, this
last slide, let me comment on that and there
are some places where you can go, these URLs
on the slide where you can find more about
NCBI services and so forth but if you want
to provide feedback write to us at the NCBI
info, info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov
and I'm afraid we are out of time but there
a lot of questions that we have not addressed
fully but I will make sure I will get them
answered and I will put that on the FTP site
and you'll get an email from automatic email
from GoTo webinar program actually but it
will have a link to that site and we will
get the Q&A document in there that will have
the answers to the other questions that people
asked and there were a lot of good ones today.
Thank you, everybody for coming and thank
you Lon, and I will go ahead and end the webinar.